avant tout un homme de famille.
Mike Bossy a marqué bien des
gens, et pas seulement grâce
à ses prouesses sportives.
♪ ♪ ♪ouhaité viouhaité viouhaite
son deuil loin des caméras,
elle a reçu de nombreux
témoignages de condoléances.
Environ 800 personnes sont
venues rendre un dernier hommage
au défunt depuis hier matin.
PIERRE CREAMER,
beau-frère de Mike Bossy
- J'étais un petit peu
dans les nuages. Je voulais pas
réaliser que Mike était décédé.
es comme aujourd'hui,
ça nous permet de mettre
un petit peu de baume
sur notre plaie.
- Le premier ministre du Québecc
a tenu à rendre hommage
à l'ancien joueur.
tellement sympathique,
tellement simple, là,
un être humain exceptionnel.
- Le drapeau du Québec a été
mis en berne à l'Assemblée
nationale. François Legault
s'est aussi dit ouvert à ce que
Mike Bossy soit commémoré.
- Est-cee... avant d'avoir
brûlé le livre des records
de la Ligue nationale,
il a fait la même chose dan
la Ligue junior majeur à Laval.
Donc, on regarde ça
actuellement.
♪ - Sur la route encore, je veux
retourner sur la route encore ♪
- Bryan Trottier a chanté
lors de la cérémonie,
à la demande des
de son ancien coéquipier.
"J'ai chanté avec tout
mon coeur, en mémoire de
notre dernière rencontre, qui
a été heureuse", a dit Trott
a souri de nouveau aujourd'hui,
malgré la douleur.
- Ça
- Un hommage sobre pour
un joueur exceptionnel.
Ici Antoine Deshaies,
Radio-Canada, Mon